i was really um  going off the deep end with uh  stressing out about  my career because it just kept going up  and up and up and it's what i've always  wanted and i like where i'm at but i i  uh  you know i needed to calm down and  breathe and  and slow down a bit and i think i've  learned to do that you know what it was  michael it was this kind of [ __ ] where  i'd never  i'd never  i was always proud of just being me  whether you know me from movies or from  playing football with me when i was 17 i  was pretty proud of being me and i  stopped kind of doing that for a while  i started knowing that if i was going to  a house party  i thought they would expect me to talk  about my movies or talk about bruce  willis or talk about  sons or sons and so i put all this  [ __ ] into my head so i would be  just kind of  moving too fast